I thought I would do some rambling again, I was shocked and I would do something to happen
because my little recording area is full of stuff, like I'm not even kidding, I'll kick
my foot out just to give you an idea of how much stuff is in here, yeah, I had to do it for you
so, I have, I literally have a painlet, originally I was actually gonna do nail tapping ASMR because
I have quite long nails right now, but I think because my nails aren't fake, like if you get fake nails it actually sounds so much better
but I've got the end of a pen and then I have a plastic pen and I was basically just gonna tap on lots of different things
um, whilst I'm rambling, I'm gonna go ear to ear because people's, the people's have spoken and you guys seem to enjoy when I'm, I'm just going off my note and going off on one and like, don't have a script or anything
I don't even know if you can hear the tapping of it, right, so I'm just gonna focus ASMR
well, it'd be tap, this is actually a nail failure that I'm tapping on
so if I move a little bit you can actually hear the like, the grit, and the grit
the sandpaper grit, um, actually I'm pretty sure, like, um, I might hit it in my throat
since whenever I swallow my throat goes like, like a frog and that's why my ASMR is like, takes so long to hit it because I'm just, I'm hitting it in all these like, tiny little things
oh my god right, this is like the same, does anyone remember playing Star Wars Battlefront?
the very first game and then when it was the loading screen the thing would go de-de-de-de-de-de-de video
whenever I do tap an ASMR it keeps happening in my head
But yeah, so that's the pen against it, and then it, no, yeah the pen, and then there's the pen lid
which sounds a bit more, a bit more hollow, not to be confused with hollow life
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I'm so funny, how'd you know?
Actually, you know what, I will tell you some, that's behind the scenes
So apparently there's like AI subtitles now which saves me so much time
But unfortunately due to one whispering and two being Scottish, the, oh, I'm not supposed to swear
I'll take that out, I just swore there, but I've taken it out, I'm a good girl
Aren't you two, please don't punish me
Right, I'll dab on something else
I've got like a little wooden stick
Oh, I just, let's make a lot of words about it, what was I saying?
I don't know if we're gone
I know I mentioned Star Wars Battlefront
And then I took out an edit of subtitles
The subtitles can never freaking understand me, because I'm whispering and I'm Scottish
It's a nightmare, like, maybe one day technology will get advanced to accept the Scottish accent
But it's not happening today
So I have to like manually fix all the subtitles and it's like I may as well just do it myself at this point
Because it takes so much time to fix them
But I really like doing subtitles because I think it's harder for a folk to understand me
So I'd rather, I'd rather make my content
I'd rather make it accessible, even though technically I'm speaking English, but...
I just realised, oh my god, I could do ear tapping as well
That's where I'm tapping your ear, what are you going to do about it?
You're doing, you're doing
Oh, you're doing the other one
Oh my god, I can tap them at the same time
Oh yeah, that's right
That's where you better tingle
Okay, I definitely know
I was going to say polydactyl
What's that thing called when you're good with both your hands?
Instead of re-hand-dominated or left hand-dominated
Polydactyl? No
Oh my goodness, what's that word?
Oh, that's going to annoy me
Okay, this next object I'm tapping on, as you hear me bend over and literally pick stuff off the floor
Professional ASMR, by the way
There's no way you're going to guess what this is
It's a headband
Does that sound like a weird headband? No
I've got one anyway
That's saying something mildly important
This is terrible tapping ASMR
He wrote this video
Actually, no one wrote it
This is called acapella
Acapella means singing without any music
Why?
This is like such a hole, like a deep
You know what?
You better start sounding like tapping ASMR
I'm going to beat you up with a headband
As with my nail
And that's it
With the freaking pinlet, it's not working
But yeah, if what we're saying is that the more organic ASMR is, it'll be done for the next thing
I got my question wrong
The more organic ASMR, because if I'm inclined to agree
Because if things start sounding a bit too professional
It doesn't like
It's not to say that someone with a professional level of recording doesn't provide tingles or whatever
But I have to admit, I like doing stuff off the top of my head
Even though I get distracted really easily
This is supposed to be tapping ASMR
And I'm currently squishing the fucking balls
So maybe you need to get back on track just a wee bit
Oh, that's my walls
Wait, hold on
Hold on
I need to pick up the pen again
I'm trying to make it work with the damn pinlet
But the pinlet doesn't even make any fake noise
Okay, the actual plastic pen makes noise
Oh yeah
Actually
Oh yeah, baby
Yeah, fuck we're saying the kind of like when I just do my own thing
And do it in the script
Like, I don't mind a roleplay, then you get me a role, me
I've got a good roleplay in my way to use the kitchen, the bathroom, the bedroom, wink, wink
But it's kind of fun just to do it off the top of my head
Because I don't feel like pressure
I don't feel pressure to perform like right now
I'm just memin'
Once it's good to tap and noise, hold on
Put that down real quick
As you hear me drop on the floor
Yeah, like, I don't feel pressure
I feel like this is just more, I don't know, griffin' off
Some people really will enjoy
Professional use more
But it's just not for me because it just, I don't know
It's not that it feels lifeless or anything
That's completely not at all
What the situation is
But I don't know, it's just nice to meme about
Not take things so seriously
And definitely not either
Again, delay for me
Ooh, really fast and slow, it's more
I've always wanted to make a fast ASMR
But I feel like it sounds so bad, like
Yeah, you tingle in your fuckin' bamboo
I'm so, maybe you tripped it
Okay, it's fine, I'll leave it in because it was actually merely humorous
But yeah, like, I don't know how fast ASMR is for me
Because I'm like, isn't this supposed to be a sleep-lake?
Shouldn't it not just be like
And good night
And relax
Well, you know, where like, I feel like fast ASMR is like
Like, I don't, I don't find that relaxing at all
But that shows me
And if it's not getting that, like, I'm ticked a
And what ASMR you get, like, all of a sudden you like that ASMR
You're not getting that ASMR
But now I have to request it
Like, honestly, I don't mind requesting ASMR
All it does not bother me, like, some creators don't like seeing it
Although I do understand, like, if a creator uploads something
And then, like, the comments are immediately like
All kias apart, all kias apart
And it's like, bro, I literally just spent so much time making a part one
At least let the video, like, I don't know, be birthed already
Like, it literally just came out of the birth canal
Let it grow, like, arms and limbs and stuff
Wait, no, let it grow
Let its freaking bones, like, I don't know
Get, get hard
If you didn't know when you're born as a baby
All your bones are like, wobbly and like, jelly and stuff
I've forgotten the word for when your bones get hard
It's like ossification
Oh, that's the word, it's ossification
And that's why, because you're born with, like, over 300 bones
But I think you end up with, like, 204
I think you're born with 314
And then you get, like, 204 by the time you're an old far
And, so yeah
Now you know, you've been educated against your own
Oh, I should do education ASMR because that stuff bids people to sleep, like, so quickly
Like, when you're getting forced to learn something
Your brain just starts tuning up
Okay
This is my favorite
Scottish fact
Well, it's not fact about Scotland
But it's a fact
Because I'm Scottish
Right, I'll just say the sentence
So if you think to yourself
What do seeds need to grow?
But you say it in that accent
W-O-T
Or wet water
Right
And in order for a seed to grow
They need water
Water
And then the O is oxygen
The breath
And then T is temperature
Because they need to be able to germinate
At a suitable temperature
And for each seed it's different
Because, you know, you can get tropical seeds that come from a climate
Or you can get hardy plants
Like, for example
Potato
And onion
They're considered hardy plants
Because they can survive quite low temperatures
Without perishing
I think cabbage is one as well, actually
But again, it depends on the type of cabbage
Because of the way that humans have
Cultured
Cultured plants
That's not wrong
That's like, oh, we give
We give at the mouth
A guitar, now the guitar's part of this culture
I don't mean like that, like, cultivation
Oh, it's hard
To have been ASMR, by the way
I think I may have been used to
Just doing these ASMRs
No one is asleep
I'm just
I'm just feeling myself, okay?
Hold on, can this stop?
Oh, yeah, you look that double
You want to guess what this is?
You will never guess, and others
What I'm currently mucking about with
It's a freaking, it's a wire
Protective plastic paper
You put the wire through
Like, I'm saying this ASMR can be resourceful
Yeah, okay, you don't need like
Fucking super expensive equipment
I should know I'm the one who spent
The one who owns expensive equipment
But anyway, yes
What was I saying?
Plants
Oh, that's a bit high pitch
I like the deeper
Deeper tabs, yes
Deep
Do you like the deep?
I mean, you don't like it deep, don't you?
What was I saying?
Oh, like
Yeah, like humans have evolved
Plants
I forgot the word
Where it's like you take the tomato
And it doesn't really look like tomatoes
Until they do today
And it's like, obviously
Supermarkets only offer
Like certain kinds of fruit and veg
And all that, but there's so many variations
So there's absolutely beautiful
Like some people listening right now
I'm gonna pull your mind
Did you know that there's purple carrots?
But they don't sell purple carrots
In the supermarkets because the average
Jewel only knows that there's orange carrots
And purple ones are too stark
But there's so many beautiful
Crops out there that we're just not
Exposed to like corn, for example
You can get multi-colored corn
That's right, not yellow
You can get purple, you can get
Little red ones as well
It's absolutely beautiful and amazing
And nature can genuinely be so pretty
And it's such a shame that
It's like hidden away from us
And tucked away from us
Because you'd never know better until you like
Go out there and reach out
And get this information to you
Instead of the information
Like coming to you or being passed out
Now some people might have like
Shifts out to their parents and maybe
They were exposed to like rich
A rich diversity of fit
And that's amazing
Like that's actually bulk jumping all that
But it's like such a shame for the people
Who never get to experience it
Unless they like accidentally stumble
Like this is the fastest pace
More whispering before
Then you slow down
I should probably try and slow down
But I'm actually
Like genuinely passionate about it
And I think it's really important I'd love to do some
Educational stuff sometimes
I'm just not very smart myself
But like just because you're a bit daft
That doesn't mean you can't learn and it doesn't mean
Like you actually
Can't try and teach others as well
Because if you didn't know
The best way to learn something
Is to actually teach someone else about it
It's like an interesting thing
I think it's like if you write it down
You're like 5% gonna remember it
If you teach it to someone
You're like 70% gonna remember it
Or something that's quite fantastic
Like honestly human psychology
And the mind is like really fascinating
Like we humans are such simple creatures
Like we crave
We crave like communication
We crave passing down knowledge to one another
No matter how big or no matter how small
Or
I just
It's beautiful, you know life's beautiful
If you look for the little things
And you know I think maybe
Some people take things like literally
Like all these flowers are beautiful
This life is beautiful
And it's like nah come on
It's about the way you smile things in life
Like the things that make you giggle or post mail
On your face like
Again if you go for a wee walk
And there's a wee bird that's screaming inside
And it's like really annoying
Like that bird's just calling out for
A wee mate or it's calling out for
His partner and being like I got some food
Go get it and it's like
I can appreciate that, that's it
That's a word
We should appreciate
And it's like
You didn't just learn it
Well you do learn it, I appreciate things
And you have to practice it as well
Like you can't just wake up and be like
Oh I am pure thankful that
Of you know I can move my toes
Today or whatever
Like
You just have to genuinely practice it
And it takes time like
I used to take the train to work
And it was absolutely beautiful
Like the sights that I could see were so beautiful
And the architecture of the buildings and all that
And I used to say to myself
Like you know what
I'm actually so lucky that I get
To witness all of this
Through my own two eyes and I get to experience it
And I get to experience
The motion of the train
And I get to experience it
And good morning to the ticket conductor
And like showing them that I've bought my ticket
And all that and
Like there's people on the train
Just enjoying looking out the window
And seeing the sights as well and it's like
Can what at the end of the day
We're actually really lucky
And yeah you know what
I do apologize, I apologize
For taking it for granted
That I take my everyday life for granted
And like literally
I'm sitting in a booth right now
My re-recorded booth that I was able to afford
Because people are so kind
And like they either support me monetarily
Or they support me just by watching my content
Because they're like okay
I'll give out my time and attention
And it's like
It's just kind of hard to wrap
And comprehend and pretend
And this is just turning to a big old
Fucking it's not Japanese
More we all know that by now
Come on, come on
But like it's just hard to conceptualize
Like there's so many people out there
Rootin' for me
And if you're Aussie, no not like that
But also if you are Aussie, yes like that
And it's just
It's all
Bizarre and wonderful life
We get to live like right now
In this moment, in this day and age
Like just it's hard to please
I'm totally going to swap that
Different type of thing next
Um
Yeah just
You know and like
Like listening to my stories
I'm like what you like listening to my stories
For I'm such a boring
Mobile
But you know what
If you think I'm entertaining
Then you know color me blushed
What did I even try and say there
Color me blushed
Okay
Like yeah just
You know
As the content creator
Say thank you and I know
I know I know or me
I've heard folks say thank you all the time
Or they didn't appreciate it and all that
But what else am I supposed to say
Like genuinely what else am I supposed to say
Like obviously I say thank you
And I like to think of my level
I'm gonna burp
That uh you know what
I'm gonna burp right in your ear
You're welcome
What was I saying
I've completely forgotten
Alright thank you
I like to think
My way of saying thank you is like
Doing these week of the videos and being like
Oh thank you for 1k
Like use an ASMR video
Like it's a special special thank you
For just saying thank you like
Like oh I feel indebt
Just because of everything
That's um
That's like
It's just actual meant on me like honestly
But meant on a good way meant on me
It's like crazy but in a good way
Although it can be meant on a bad way
Like always meant on you know what I mean
Woah
I'm teaching
I'm gonna try hard and actually
Put you in sleep this time
Some people like
Like humming
Like to sleep
But my voice is not very good
I can't maintain that
Cause my voice is like being a bit
Robish
I don't even mind singing
A wee bit of Zelda you know what I mean
Like da da da
Da da da da
Bo bo bo da da
It's like so fast
I need to research like slow lullaby
I wanna make lots of videos
I wanna make a lullaby one
Where I play with your hair with my nails
Cause I got long nails right now
Don't know if you can hear me
I mean yeah you can hear that cause I can hear
But you like
Play with your hair
Well stop
Sing slow lullaby
It's about to unravel lullaby
I can't wait to sing
Again
Okay well actually
Let's just nail tapping
I'm just cheating
But yeah I'll do like a proper nail tapping
One
When I get fake nails
Cause they use like hard acrylic
Oh my god acrylic is such a good
It's more wonderful
Acrylic
Oh my god
I just tingled
I didn't
I like I tingled a lot of stuff
If I listen back to
If I'm not talking again
It's not that I don't like my voice or anything
But I just like I can't even hear my voice
Like I'm so used to my voice
I'm so used to my accent
It doesn't like have an effect on me
But if I do a really ugly hair
Please it's my favorite tingle
Like hair brush and anything
I just
I'll just generally scratch my head right now
Don't mind me
But like those are my favorite ones
Oh yeah
Actually I want to do a video
Where I do everyone's favorite trigger
For like one minute
And the video is like an hour long
But everyone's just gonna say
You're the wicked one
But it's still a cute concept
I think you're just a little bit
To do ear kissing this morning
I really should probably stop doing this
Round plan once I keep
I come in, I genuinely think I'm like
Oh I'm gonna ease that
I'm gonna do so much ear tapping this morning
And then I never freakin' do it
I just get too excited
Okay
Can't blame me, I'm like a little
Little puppy, too excited
Maybe
I'll just, I'll do some
Ear tapping and then we'll all pretend
That we fail to sleep at the end
Of the ear tapping and I'll
Like just do it for a bit
And then we can pretend it's a real
ASMR video whilst literally
No one fell asleep to it honestly
I say that as I drop some more shade
On the ground, oh wait I'm not
Dropping pen ASMR
We've had new ASMR triggers
Just dropped essentially me dropping a pen
On the floor, you ready?
Three, two, one
Whoa
But yeah, okay
I'll do ear tapping, I'm not gonna talk
Or anything else, I don't wanna ruin that
And then we'll all unanimously pretend
That this is real ASMR, okay
You like that? Okay, well done
Thank you
Thank you, thank you for
Thank you for tuning in, thank you for subscribing
And liking, and you know
If you know where it is in the showbiz baby
But hi, right
I'll do some tapping
But good night, sweet dreams
And um, see you
Tingle you in the next ASMR video
Let's go
I'm really glad I chose
But for serious
Please, please rest well
Um
Or continue to enjoy your days
I know some people listen when they're just like
Playing video games or whatever
Oh my god
Oh my god you're messing up in your video game
He's behind you
Bye
See you next time, okay
I'll call you
Bye